How do you balance the idea of checking
the ego well in an interview scenario
where you need to talk about
yourself? Okay, so good question.
I,
I would say in that situation,
and this is something that it's not
just an interview situation where you're
going to need to do that. I mean, you're
dealing with your, your superiors,
you know, throughout the course of
your career, whatever that may be.
You're constantly interacting
with people and you,
you're gonna want to make
an impression. Uh, so I,
I think one of the best ways to do this
is instead of you speaking about why
you're so awesome,
just state facts of let's
say accomplishments and let
them speak for themselves.
In other words, you know,
you wouldn't want to say a,
yeah,
Yup. I am the best project manager in
the entire world. Right. That's not,
that sounds ego centric.
You know,
instead you'd say, uh, you know, I got
this, we had a $38 million project,
got it done on time, under
budget, ahead of schedule.
And when I got done with that,
when they moved me to another project
that was off track and we got that one
back on schedule and
back on track as well.
So that's the kind of
experience that I've had.
And I'd love to bring that here to this
company. Right. So you're not, you're not,
you know, there's a hint of, hey, this
is what I did. I can get some stuff done.
But you're not saying, listen, I'm better
than the people you currently have,
so you should hire me because I'm the
best cause you don't want to do that. Um,
and you know, so yeah, just
build, think about it, you know,
before you go in, how, what,
what experience that you have represents
the good qualities that you have.
So then you can say, if they say, you
know, how are you at meeting timelines?
You don't say, I am perfect. I'm never
late. I'm dope. You just say, you say,
you say, well, you know, as
far as meeting timelines,
here's a bunch of projects
that I got completed on time.
The only one that I missed was one that
we had to roll back because whatever
that way you're actually showing a little
bit more humility. You're saying, hey,
here's what happened. You're being logical
about it and you'll speak into that.
I actually got a good question
that's similar to this one. Um,
about what's the best way to interview
people to see if they can be in a
leadership position.
And this is really hard.
This is really hard cause it's really
hard to interviews and working.
I worked with all kinds of different
companies and everybody always has,
you know, hey, what's the best
way to interview? And Man,
I interviewed this guy
and he seems so great.
Or I interviewed this woman and she
seemed incredible and or her paper looked
great,
you know,
she looked great on paper and we hired
her and she's a disaster or he's a
disaster or whatever the case may be.
Because,
because there's people that are
very good interviewers, right?
I mean there's people that can interview
well, they have the gift of Gab.
They can, they can bs their way through
anything and make themselves sound good.
So it can be really hard to identify if
someone's good is actually going to be
fit for a leadership position
or really any position.
So one of the things that that I always
tell people to do is when you go into
these,
when you want to ask interview questions,
ask them scenario based questions and
say, okay, here's what's going on.
You got these three people
in your department and one
of the people has come to
you and said that they think there might
be something illegal going on with the
other two. What actions do
you take? And, and you know,
have a scenario built out that you can
actually talk through and see where
they'd go and see what their mindset is
and see what they're going to develop as
a plan and see how they
would execute plans.
So it's a great way of
figuring out how people think.
And then you know, even that's not a
guarantee because there's people that can,
can navigate those types
of answers as well.
So you don't want that you can do is
hire people on a little bit of a trial
basis.
And that can be difficult.
Some situations where people are walking
away from one job into another job and
they're not going to do it
on a 90 day trial basis.
But when you do have that opportunity,
it's a good thing to do as well. Um,
but hey,
so going back to the first question
about keeping your ego in check in an
interview,
like I said,
be confident but not cocky and let the
facts of your experience speak for your,
your abilities rather than
beating your own chest.
Yeah. So it's almost like, I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong here,
so you s you essentially,
even if you're talking yourself up,
you just, you simply state the
fact that you just state the fact,
don't say your opinion about it.
Like, just like how you were saying,
please state the facts.
What I did, you know, we turn
this project around, we got it on,
on track and on budget and that,
that's the type of,
that's the type of experience that
I have in those situations. Right.
Just like how you're saying,
even if someone had got like
an award to be the best,
whatever sales right of the year,
that right tells me that you're the
best whatever of the year. And then, um,
like to say that in a
factual way would be,
I was recognized as the
best guy in the world.
Instead of saying I'm the best guy in
the world, who's my award to prove it,
you know? So it's like you're seeing the
fact that you were recognized, you know,
not so much the fact fingered way of
doing it. Stick to the facts, right.
Just the facts,
the facts.